andrew has recently published this I I
thought quite excellent book the
internet is not the answer it's his
third book several years before he
published a book that created a great
deal of stir called cult of the amateur
followed it with a book called Digital
vertigo this is his next salvo in a
series that offers I think very
interesting and constructive critiques
of what's going on in the shared world
of the Internet and the businesses that
surround it Andrew takes some pride and
pleasure in being a controversial estai
I think instead of stirring things up I
have every confidence that we'll be able
to have an interesting and lively
conversation here I I do think it's
worth giving a little bit of Andrews
background before he began writing he is
a Silicon Valley entrepreneur actually
of the same generation that I am of
Class of 95 of the people who are trying
to build internet-based businesses
before they even bother putting a 1.0
after Tim's web he prior to that as a
historian and a teacher of history and
that's something that comes into play
quite a deal with the internet it's not
the answer
it spends a lot of time at these days in
Silicon Valley leading conversations and
salons around some of the issues involve
the book and other issues around Silicon
Valley culture and values and
aspirations I'm really happy that we
have him here educated thank you well
it's a real honor to be here and I
apologize if I break down and the
terrible coughing but don't take it
personally
it's an honor to be here for a couple of
reasons some obviously very
distinguished members of the audience
and in the book I really do focus on the
history of the internet the first the
first version of the book was to
polemical and my publishers Morgan
entropy at Grove Atlantic was a very
good publisher in New York came back to
me and he said you got to have a history
of the infinite
so the first two chapters are the first
real two chapters really do tell the
history of the internet and some some
people here very important roles in that
but I think MIT has perhaps in
institutional terms the most important
role Vannevar Bush and I really begin
with Norbert Weiner and his idea of
cybernetics and the way in which that
became the sort of pioneering foundation
of thinking about the web so being at
MIT from my point of view as a real
honor
so yeah this book is called the Internet
is not the answer some people said
probably including Ethan well the title
is a little vulgar and yeah books you
know just for those of you who are
writers books need vulgar titles to sell
but I think the problem with the title
is not its vulgarity I'm not saying the
Internet will never be the answer and
one of the things we'll probably talk
about today is the way in which the
Internet needs to become the answer it
has to become the operating system for
21st century life that is unavoidable we
can't turn the clock back we can't go
back to some idea or some analog idea in
the 20th century but my biggest problem
actually with the title is the word the
Internet I think the word the Internet
itself has become slightly archaic I was
talking to Ethan about this earlier it's
it's too narrow a word I mean imagine in
1812 writing a book called the the
industrial is not the answer or
something like that what I've tried to
do in this book is talk about these in
in in he galleon terms these world
historic these structural shifts in the
nature of things I believe that and I'm
sure I'd be interested to see whether
you guys agree with it but I believe
we're living through one of the great
changes in history in structural terms
in economic and social terms and it's
being driven as it
was at the beginning of the 19th century
by technology Bryn Johnson and McAfee I
know their hair as well I'm sure you
will know they're both the second
machine machine age talk about it as the
second Machine Age other people have
different definitions but I think what
is clear is that we're living
increasingly perhaps in something called
the networked age the distributed age
the noddle age the age of the digital
revolution and you guys are the
architects of this the ideologist maybe
in some way the engineers you understand
this as well as I do I tell the history
of the internet in the book for the
first two chapters and it was a very
good learning experience for me
obviously I became quite familiar with
with the most important architects but
it also reminded me of a couple of
things firstly how old the Internet is
the first computer to computer
communication was in 1969 so almost 50
years of that in a Tim's invention of
the World Wide Web is 20 more than 25
years old now and having told the
history some people would say and this
is often the refrain you hear in Silicon
Valley
well it's too early we can't come to any
conclusions it's too early and I've been
hearing that since 1995
it's always too early we can't make any
judgments it's rather like for those of
you who are parents it's rather like
making a judgment about a badly behaved
adolescent it's always too early they'll
grow out of this they'll grow up and of
course sometimes they do and sometimes
they don't but I believe that we're at a
point now where we can come to some
general conclusions about whether or not
this thing which we call the Internet
the digital revolution the networked
world is succeeding now I focus on its
claims and I have a great deal of
respect for the architects who wanted
this world to be more equal to be fairer
to undermine many of the traditional
hierarchical structures of 20th century
industrial and
cultural life as Ethan said my first
book was about the cultural industries
and was a kind of defense of a certain
kind of cultural elite which was very
controversial
this book is less and I'm not sure
whether I should be happy about this
this book is less controversial I think
because things have changed dramatically
since 2007 when I wrote cult of the
amateur I think more and more people are
coming around to my position it's not
just me there are a number of other
thinkers I know sherry Turkle is at the
University Jaron Lanier Nick Carr
there's a number of us making quite
similar points about what's happened so
what I do is I say okay it was promised
to be it was promised to create a better
world a world where more people would
have more opportunity a world of more
democracy and cultural terms above all
allows a world of Economic Opportunity I
quote Kevin Kelly a lot Kevin I'm sure
he's been at this place as well Kevin in
his book the new laws of the new law the
new laws of the new economy was very
influential in the 90s he's still very
influential and what I conclude in the
book and this may be a beginning for a
conversation is that so far the Internet
is not the answer so far the Internet is
not as that the digital revolution
Network society is not doing what it
what we expected it to do now let me add
the caveat but I don't believe that
there is some conspiracy I'm quite
critical of many Silicon Valley
companies Google and Facebook but I
don't believe they are conspiring to
wreck the Internet there are natural
laws winner-take-all laws laws of the
network which I get power laws which I
get into in some detail in the book I
don't think the internet has been
subverted I don't think there are evil
people out there who wanted to destroy
it but the consequence nonetheless is of
a disappointing outcome so far excuse me
and and let me talk about three areas
very briefly where I think
the disappointment is the most salient
and then perhaps we can open it up maybe
Ethan once there are some questions the
first is inequality now we know that
people like Thomas Piketty Reich Krugman
they've all written very important books
and articles about inequality and had I
always used this but now I've got Tim
here too had not that I would wish that
would have happened but had you been
knocked over in Geneva in 1988 not
invented the web we'd still have
inequality I'm not arguing that without
the web there wouldn't be inequality I'm
not arguing that economic inequality
today the hollowing out of the middle
this increasing disparity between a tiny
new plutocracy and an underclass and the
decimation of the old middle class thank
you very much is entirely the cause of
the internet but what I do argue in the
book is it's contributing it's
contributing the so-called sharing
economy is anything but sharing it's
contributing to a new structure of half
employed people selling their labor on
platforms the undermining of the old
secure jobs of the industrial age and
the increasing disappearance of a kind
of dignity of labour it's of course in
Silicon Valley contributing through the
massive financial success of companies
like Google and Facebook where a tiny
group of technologists have become
infinitely rich you know Jeff Bezos Mark
Zuckerberg Larry Page Sergey Brin Mark
Zuckerberg they're all worth thirty
billion dollars that they put their cash
together they could solve the Greek
crisis the Greek financial crisis
overnight so we're talking about massive
aggregation of wealth and I think that
that inequality is one of the three
reasons why so far at least the internet
hasn't been successful it's also true in
cultural terms the power laws and
economics also work in cultural spheres
so we have the appearance of these new
kind of cultural barons on networks like
Twitter and Facebook with
millions of followers and then again a
kind of an underclass of people now a
woman at Harvard Business School could
Anita Elks Berg written our important
book called Blockbuster in which she
makes the point that the entertainment
industry itself is is even more unequal
now even more of a blockbuster economy
than in the than in the analog age so
again this isn't just me saying this
secondly I talked about the crisis of
employment I have two chapters in the
book back to back I have one chapter on
Rochester and Kodak is the
quintessential industrial company that
employed 150,000 people and then of
course I talked about Instagram which
didn't necessarily replace Kodak but we
had this symbolic shift from a Kodak
moment in history to an Instagram moment
when Instagram sold to Facebook a couple
of years ago same time when Insur when
Facebook when Kodak went bust
Instagram employed 15 people and that at
the time seemed unbelievable but it
actually seems less unbelievable now
when you think that Facebook then went
on to acquire whatsapp which employed
about 55 people for 20 billion dollars
so we have a crisis of employment I
write quite a lot about the growth of
artificial intelligence the appearance
of machine learning and the way in which
this technology is again
disintermediating skilled laborer a
couple of weeks ago I did a debate in
London with Walter Isaacson about this
and we talked about the way what was on
the other side and agree with me but we
talked I at least talked about the way
in which through the Moravec paradox
that actually all this technology was
resulting in a challenge to skilled
labor to lawyers and doctors and
accountants and above all else teachers
so the impact of networked society
unemployment I think is very very
troubling very problematic particularly
the way in which the most innovative
Silicon Valley companies are now
essentially becoming our
official intelligence companies Google
is the best case thirdly and in this
sense I have to quote Ethan because I
was thrilled when he I was finishing my
book and I read a piece by him where was
it
Atlantic yeah I was in the Atlantic in
which he described the original sin you
know unambiguous biblical language the
original sin of the internet being it's
free business model now this is a very
well-informed audience I probably don't
need to tell you but a lot of people
wonder them themselves okay well
Instagram saw to Facebook for a billion
dollars in it it only employed 15 people
how is it possible to generate that kind
of wealth that kind of value when
there's only 15 people working for it
and of course the value of Instagram is
in what Mike Moritz another very
distinguished Silicon Valley investor
describes as these new data factories
these ubiquitous always open data
factories where we're all contributing
to Instagram or Facebook or Twitter or
even Google in a sense we are all
working for these companies but of
course we are not being remunerated
we're not being financially rewarded now
some people might say well we know what
we're doing and some of us do and for
many people it's a fair exchange but of
course what Ethan I think meant when he
talked about the original sin is that in
this economy in this free economy we're
all being transformed into product
because the dominant business model of
the internet is advertising Google was
the company that I think pioneered this
has been developed by many so-called web
2.0 companies since these are big data
companies whose value is predicated on
their knowledge of us Eric Schmidt
sometimes been very clear about this he
says you know we know more about you
than you know about yourselves I'm not
sure if Eric was joking there he has a
funny sense of humor but certainly these
companies do so this data economy has
created a surveillance that then as as
Bruce Schneier I'm sure you will know
him I'm sure he's does he is he peeing
here
he's got a new book out yeah we'll get
him over here I was just on the phone
okay is he here okay well he talks about
the dominant business model of the
internet being surveillance so
inequality unemployment surveillance now
I could sit here someone's gonna stick
up their hands oh oh well the Internet's
been good in some ways and I don't deny
that I have a couple of pages in the
book I make it clear you know make it
clear I couldn't written the book but
I'm is you know I always do this I'm as
I got tissues in one thing you know I
was
I'm as wired as anywhere and I'm not
Luddite in any way but there are lot
many many books including I'm sure
people here written about why the
Internet is a good thing so it's not I
guess a balanced book but balanced books
are boring I think but it is a polemic
it's an attempt to wake people up to the
current digital reality and it's
hopefully and it's having quite a lot of
resonance appreciate you all coming but
maybe that's it wait yeah so here's how
we thought we would structure this and
rusev laid out the the core argument of
the book which in many ways is that we
hope the internet would help us find
answers to some of these great problems
like inequality meaningful work there's
other ways in which the Internet has
proved not only to be not an answer but
but actually a much more aggravated
problem around issues like privacy and
surveillance I want to ask a couple of
questions okay having enjoyed the book a
great deal this weekend and I want to
open it up into a broader conversation
we're going to keep in mind the fact
that and Andrews is holding it together
now I'm enjoying my center line and so
forth but so I I think the first
question I want to ask is is what is the
answer right so you put forward a very
thorough critique which says that a lot
of these aspirations a lot of these sort
of mid-90s
utopian aspirations are wholly
unrealistic okay you're not in the camp
of the people who suggest that we shut
off the internet
walk away yeah max you do have an answer
you actually title a chapter the answer
yeah what's the essence of the answer
you told me that was wrong
yeah yeah I don't think anyone talks
about switching on I mean even the Daily
Mail in England doesn't talk about
switching the thing off I don't know
yeah maybe in North Korea or something
but well I think the way to begin to
think about the answer is to imagine
we're back in 1812 in England and we're
having this great debate about the
impact of the Industrial Revolution on
work on inequality on the behavior of
the new elites and the Industrial
Revolution was far from ideal of course
we know that I'm not claiming that it
was solved in every respect but many of
the problems were solved through
political means technology didn't solve
the problems the early problems of the
Industrial Revolution technology really
didn't solve pollution I've got this
phrase I'm not entirely sure what it
means but it's sort of sexy data is the
new pollution data didn't so technology
didn't solve the problem of child labor
in factories technology didn't save it
didn't solve the problem of the problem
of rubber barons or the cultural problem
of rubber barons and they agreed and
their lack of responsibility to society
and I think we are entering if you like
the political stage now of the web the
first you know bomber talked about the
Internet when he came out to Silicon
Valley a few weeks ago he talked about
it as the Wild West and I think he was
in a sense warnings the entrepreneurs of
Silicon Valley that we're on the brink
of this new age the political age and I
think the answer is partly political I
think if there is one core enemy in my
book it's the libertarian
the pizza tears and the Travis colonics
of Silicon Valley who think that the
market is always the solution that the
market will resolve all these problems
that all we need is to keep our hands
government's the problem regulation is
the problem legislation is the problem
and if only we can keep our hands off
technology off the web of these
companies then the thing will be
resolved and that certainly wasn't the
case in the industrial revolution so I
think part of the solution is a
political solution and we're seeing it
and we're seeing these companies behave
a lot better we're seeing it yet uber is
the classic case it really did behave
very a responsibility until it
recognized that it was having to fight
you know every local authority around
the world we're seeing it now in the
increasing attention the EU is looking
in in antitrust issues with Google we're
certainly seeing it in the right to be
forgotten law now I'm sure most of you
aren't in favor of that I'm not sure if
I am in favor of that I I recognize I
had a debate with Jonathan Zittrain on
this and I recognize it's certainly far
from being an ideal law but we do need
regulate we do need legislation on data
we do need to figure out political
solutions to the data issue after all
we're just I think McAfee talks about
you know he's got that metaphor of the
chess board you know where every piece
every piece on the board adds another
grain of rice and by the end you get to
this enormous you know I've got more
grains of rice than in the history of
the world I think we're on the verge of
that when it comes to data with
self-driving cars with the Internet of
Things with wearables with devices being
in walls with smart cities we're still
at the fairly early stages of our debate
about data so I think one solution is
government one solution is more
regulation
I think another solution is more
corporate responsibility I have a couple
of examples in the book of ways in which
companies work together for example to
fight online piracy I think it would be
wrong to exclusively
and on government but I also remind
people in if I make this specific but
I'm certainly doing it in my talks the
regulation and innovation aren't
incompatible
I mean imagine we were imagine we were
back in the late 1990s and there hadn't
been the antitrust case against
Microsoft Microsoft would have crushed
Google Microsoft never would have
allowed Google to become such a dominant
player in search in 2000 2001 so I think
regulation actually enables innovation
sometimes and I think it's wrong to see
those as polar opposites so I think
that's one place to start and you think
that's entirely wrong no I don't I
actually think it's an incredible parts
out and as someone who to work to this
audience or to Washington DC or where
well so if I summarize the argument in
some ways it is that we've reached the
political moment right so we've had this
incredible flourish and innovation we're
in a very different economy than we were
20 or 30 years ago or take the parallel
to the Industrial Revolution suddenly
there are a lot of negative responses to
the side effects of that technology in
the u.s. you end up with Teddy Roosevelt
showing up to bust the tress you end up
with progressive error reforms and
coming out of this but asking us to
suddenly get enthusiastic about the
government being the solution to this I
don't know if you've looked in on
congressional approval ratings lately
for instance or even presidential
approval ratings that's a very very hard
sell and I think that that even
antitrust is the sort of thing where the
people who in many ways sort of aligned
themselves with no we really are looking
for these values of Omanis we really are
looking for these values of innovation
found ourselves wondering who we were
rooting for when you have less than
taking on Microsoft because it does feel
like an awfully big hammer to sort of
hit it with so I I I think you're
gnosis is right I'm trying to imagine
who the Teddy Roosevelt is or what the
citizen movement is that takes us into
regulation and I'm wondering how we
regulate without killing what's
interesting and organic and fertile
about this space because I think we can
all agree that there's been a lot in
this creative moment that could have
been regulated out of existence had we
not been very careful I creamed them I
mean I'm not disagreeing but I I think
somewhat you can come up with all sorts
of other alternatives crowd-sourced
management but or some other kind of
network solution but those don't work I
think when it comes to this yeah do you
think I mean there's no I haven't seen
any evidence that they work so we can we
can put on our Rose tinted glasses and
we can hope that there are other
alternatives I've been one of the
biggest problems today and this is kind
of outside the book I mean maybe so much
the subject for another book is that we
have two speeds in the world we have
internet speed and we have government
speed again I probably don't need to
tell you guys that we have a fundamental
problem with governance with legitimacy
and leadership and the nature of
politics and we have it's incredible
innovation coming out of Silicon Valley
which is encrypted which is remarkably
quick and you know the Google model is
kind of move forward and don't worry
about any of the consequences and by the
time anyone wakes up to it it's too late
but the problem is is that there's no
alternative to government what's the
alternative so one one possible
alternative within this and I'm now
trying to figure out how to play Peter
teal which is not a role that I
particularly enjoy playing is the role
that basically says these companies are
all potentially extremely fragile you
and I can both remember a moment at
which Yahoo was the dominant player
within the space and no one wanted to
figure out how to cross them it's
possible that Microsoft was was laid low
by lesson but I think in many case
we would look at the antitrust decision
and say it was pretty weak T in the
scheme and sort of what came up for it
isn't the most powerful thing within
this the ability for consumers to shift
very rapidly if we were as concerned as
you want us to be about surveillance any
sane person would get off Facebook
abandon it in an instant and and find a
more security respecting better-behaved
platform given that these companies have
no tangible assets other than the
loyalty of people who choose to use them
is is antitrust really where you need to
go or do you simply not need more
alternatives on the horizon you you you
have it in for Amazon in this book
you're very concerned what I have aim
for Amazon for three reasons their labor
practices their impact on retail stores
particularly book stores and Asthma
increasingly a monopolist in publishing
their behavior towards small publishers
yeah you know I like every being a
Amazon's like pornography we all use it
we just don't talk about it it's a great
service they never screw up but it's
still there are many problems with it
if we go after Amazon do are we kind of
in the market to give us another
bookseller or we can in the market to
give us competing everything stores do
we somehow take down Amazon and we
return to the American Main Street
because you seem to admit that you know
companies like Kodak weren't laid low by
Instagram it was a way of accelerating
and already I'm going process yeah and
I'm not going with antitrust do we end
up with a number Amazon coming in its
wake do we end up what's the situation
you hope about coming out of the century
well firstly and you're right on Kodak
and I talk about that you know Kodak
he's Kodak screwed up you know Kodak
were the people who invented the digital
camera and never developed it so you
know in some ways we I mean I'm not
sympathetic to Kodak I'm just Kim to
sympathetic to the people who work to
code that
even so so your question is so the
practical question is what are we hoping
for so you are criticizing well what I'm
hoping for when it comes to women what
I'm hoping for is and then Brad stone
talks about this at the end of his book
on Amazon that unlike - I don't think
monopolies are a good thing they're
certainly not good for consumers and
they're not good for society so
historically antitrust cases have
resulted in weakening companies that
hasn't always resulted in more
monopolies so you're saying that if we
we we we shackle Amazon or we shackle
Google that you'll just get bigger
monopolies is that your fear the answer
you're putting forward the answer that I
hear you putting forward is this is the
political moment this is the governance
moment we need to come in
we need meaningful regulation on data
I'm with you on that
we need antitrust I think I'm probably
with you on that I'm asking you to give
me the affirmative future you get to do
what you want to do we elect you you are
now Silicon Valley's representative you
start a digital caucus within Congress
what is what what is the world that
you're hoping for Theodore
well I would certainly want government
to be able to catch up I would want
government to learn Silicon Valley speed
and be able to deal with with technology
learn about technology and I would one
Silicon Valley entrepreneurs to become
more responsible you know I have quite a
lot of quite a lot of coverage in the
blog some of it rather satirical about
the behavior of Silicon Valley
entrepreneurs they need to grow up they
need to become more responsible and I
think of all the companies the worst is
Facebook because they're so
untrustworthy if you look at their
internet.org initiative which is
essentially an attempt to get the next
two or three billion people of the world
online it's really an excuse to to get
to transform the Internet into Facebook
it's really turning the front door of
the internet into Facebook and one of
the things that I've really worked on in
the book is sort of attacking the
hypocrisy attacking the idea
particularly I think of a company like
Facebook the presents themselves as
improving a lot of mankind and are
actually only simply promoting
themselves I mean the the political
details are complicated but I think
there has to be a political solution so
you can't imagine how deeply
uncomfortable it is for me Android it
took to both find myself quoted in this
book and then find you making arguments
that I find myself making to the press
about things like internet talk why I'm
terribly worried that we found ourselves
in the same side it's very disconcerting
to me why I'm wondering
sannen and just to come back on that
it's not disconcerting to me because I
always knew and I it's not just me no
but I think that as I said there's a
group of people who are making these
points now whether it's Terkel or linea
or car myself
there's a number of others and we all
started in this community so it's not as
if we were you know we began as
reactionaries or activists of some sort
of what so this is and this will be the
last question for me I want open this up
because I know that people are waiting
to jump into this but last question for
me and all of us is I think there's a
lot of us who share many of the
critiques that you're putting forward
have many of the concerns that you're
putting forward but when we look for
answers they are internet centric
answers yeah they may be answers that
say yeah we have to organize we have to
get political we have to build movements
but when we look at this networked world
turning away from the internet seems
like a non option if not just an unwise
option how did we build the bridge
between people like Tim who are deeply
engaged with thinking about how we get a
web we want but I I and tell me if I'm
wrong tip I can't really imagine you
know Tim coming in with with with sort
of an Internet as
the answer as as his lead argument with
him that how do we how do i bridge you
guys basically how do i bridge between
people who are deeply deeply deeply
invested in the future of the internet
but willing to accept some if not most
of your critiques but are gonna look for
those solutions very much within these
same technology are we deluding
ourselves or do we need some of that you
know value sphere to come in instead of
influence that the current Silicon
Valley geyser yeah I mean that's a great
question so I I do spend quite you know
a few pages in the book on tim himself
on his role and to me he sort of
epitomizes the public spirited nature of
the first part of the history of the
infinite up until you know 92 93 the
appearance of Netscape and then the
radical commercialization of the web so
I do in the history juxtapose this
public spirited Internet of Tim a
Vannevar boorish of Norbert whiner of
JCR Licklider of these remarkably gifted
and publicly spirited people who one
particularly didn't seem to be busy I
mean I'm sure they needed to eat but
they weren't particularly interested in
the aggregation of massive wealth and
then this new wave of you know
Zuckerberg zand Beezus I do actually
make the argument that had Larry Page
and Sergey Brin been around in the 50s
they would have been very much part of
the MIT community so I don't believe
there's a new it's probably even
Zuckerberg I don't believe that there's
a new type it's a new world I could it
sounds like it's Stanford's fall that's
what you're saying
yeah I'm Berkeley said that everything
Stan fits for I think I did have a
response to your I think we have to be
really careful to create this in again
coming back to your biblical metaphors
we have to be very careful in our
history of the internet if we say okay
the first part of the Internet was this
wonderfully altruistic publicly spirited
period financed by government and often
of course defense industries it
certainly wasn't perfect in any way in
in every way and now this new world is
one of a radical commercialization and
the an enormous greed you know the
Travis kalanick of the world I think we
have to be very careful to avoid
becoming nostalgia sore self and believe
that we can go back to that earlier
period because we can't and I think the
idea of reinventing the Internet as a as
a public Internet of going back well
whilst it's certainly very attractive in
many ways it can't be done I don't see
how it could be practical so I think we
have to avoid that I mean my I would
guess my early you know timís talks
about often I think I quote him in the
book of having a Bill of Rights for the
Internet
I wouldn't necessarily disagree with
that but my focus is on a bill of
responsibilities so it's this issue of
rights versus responsibilities than in
my mind but the fact that I'm here the
fact that you know that you invited me
and that you recognize that some of my
arguments are coherent means also that
we have entered a new period where many
of the original be evangelists optimists
are now troubled that they recognize
that this thing isn't working as it as
it was supposed to and rather than just
stepping back and assuming that the
market will solve it you recognize that
there need to be a
Solutions now whether it's government or
some other external I wish there was
something an alternative to government I
just don't see it I don't know where it
exists I don't know where it will come
from so you know for those of us who do
continue to teach history you've done a
great job of setting us up with a
Hegelian dialectic here right we had we
have the the government-sponsored happy
identic internet before the fall we have
this commercial Internet
you know dragging us into the realm of
surveillance and such both of which are
radical oversimplifications it demands
some sort of synthesis to move us
forward
does anyone either have the synthesis
the solution to where we're going or at
least a good question to make sure that
we can allow Andrew to live up to as
provocative reputation and make sure we
have a good argument as well as a good
conversation you know start us up I'm
kind of interested to hear you compare
your internet follow the history paths
of capitalism it was many problems at
the first moment and this piece itself
and came into being at a present age and
are you satisfied with capitalism today
well that's a big question um well I
think there is a you know and I think
some of the one or two of the criticisms
of the book say that I'm not writing
about the internet I'm writing about
capitalism but the reality is that they
are inseparable and that's why this idea
of the Internet is the operating system
for 21st century life is really
important think about the way in which
Oberer or Airbnb or TaskRabbit are
reinventing work labor transportation
think about the way in which these
supposed sharing companies are rewriting
the laws of capitalism so I big is
increasingly hard to separate 21st
century capitalism from that the network
and we know that every industry now is
about to be reinvented by the network
it's education whether it's health care
whether it's energy we're really seeing
it with transportation and hospitality
so the idea it began in media when we're
in 95 in that was music it was movies it
was boy it wasn't even move as it was it
was newspapers it was books but today
every industry is about to be changed I
don't think it's possible to actually
separate the internet from capitalism I
think they've become so intertwined they
be so tangled up together that
increasingly we're when we're talking
about capitalism we're talking about if
you like a digital kind of capitalism
and that's the polemic in the book I'm
saying that this capitalism doesn't work
that it's a return to the robber baron
capitalism with the radical inequalities
of the early 19th century doesn't mean
I'm against capitalism and I often make
speeches in America I did one with Jeff
Jarvis who's a friend but he's always
critical of me anytime I even criticize
capitalism he said I'm a European
socialist you know and I think we have
to be realistic and not always fall back
on well you can be critical of
capitalism without being a socialist you
can be critical of capitalism without
being against the market I still believe
in the market I believe in the profit
principle I believe that the market is
the best system for a ranging society
but it can't be completely unregulated
as the current digital revolution is
making it so by the way we're gonna
actually throw a market-based incentive
on this the best question for Andrew
wins this copy of the book which I've
just bought from the back of the room
because I already have two and I'll sign
it at home and he'll sign it so we'll
throw that out there and I see that's
already the only with
yes Susan in the queue the idea that
market is should be free requires
constant intervention by state itself so
state improve means to ensure that
market is active free so the state has
been doing that so how will you
reconcile - a lot of stuff a lot of
intervention to ensure that market
remains as it is what can you give me an
example of that so but early you you've
got someone sitting here and saying that
he wants more market intervention so
you're saying that that government is
already intervening doing sure yes
government is intervening to ensure that
the market at any time will you see that
so classical example would be the 16th
century physiocrats example when there
was great trade taking place and they
realize that when they will fix the
grain prices instead of actually
bringing down the prices it would result
in scarcity because people will not
invest in showing the seeds so whenever
they realize that right so we face this
as given that when the government
intervenes in this it's going to have
unwanted secondary effects how do we
think about that person well there was
unwanted secondary effects of anything
you can always come up with excuses
against the government intervening but
when you have a serious problem
when you have say the problem of
Napoli's when you have increasing
inequality in society when you have I
think this looming problem of labor of
what we're going to do in a world of
increasing increasingly intelligent
machines we can't worry about that we
can't worry that there will be
unforeseen consequences in a u.s.
framework out number one seem like the
ultimate imperialist and number two
being able to actually enforce it in a
way that achieves the objectives you
stated well that's a really good
question I think one of the things
that's happened is that the two things
have happened one is that as you say the
Internet is increasingly and this
reflects a broader issue in America the
global nature of the Internet has really
been an excuse for these massively
wealthy powerful multinational American
companies to become even wealthier and
more powerful and I think Americans are
uncomfortable with that idea but I also
think there's this idea that the
internet would be global it was one of
the great dreams that it would do away
with traditional boundaries you go back
to John Perry Barlow zai dia of the
internet representing a global system
that would do away with the nation's
they're do away with traditional
boundaries and the reality of the
Internet is it's fragmenting into many
different Internet's for better or worse
you know I'm no great fan of the Russian
government or the Chinese government or
the Iranian government but the reality
of the 21st century Internet is it's
fragmenting there's an int
you know there's an Iranian internet
there's a Russian internet there's a
Chinese internet and there's no that's a
great question that's a really good
question and I never thought about it
like that but I think it's an
interesting comparison to go back to the
government in the governmental
institutions and the sort of the
development of democracy and perhaps to
understand that the achievements of
government in the 19th century in terms
of regulating some of the excesses of
the Industrial Revolution were bound up
in the revolution of government itself
I'm not sure what distributed government
means I mean do you want to say more
about that well then why'd you use it
when they use it what did you think of
it as sort of notable government I mean
well can you think of some examples of
how that could work I mean these are
great questions I don't mean to be
critical and as a for instance on this
right you you're seeing movements coming
out of Brazil for instance with the
Marco Saville which is a jointly
authored piece of legislation which has
become one of the main you know sort of
the the the the centerpiece of brazil's
regulations of the internet and it was
written both by a small group of
professionals but with contributions
from about 2,000 citizens participating
within it a lot of people are sort of
wondering whether we might end up seeing
this political shift at the same moment
as you're talking about a regulatory
shift yeah well what's interesting is of
course a lot of that experimentation is
happening precisely in these digital
spaces because they allow for a much
broader set of participation well let me
also say something about my critique of
the Potter I think as I have a little
bit of this in the book the problem with
the politics of the you know where it
was hoped for example that occupy would
mature into a concrete political
organization but it didn't we all know
the catastrophe the tragedy of the Arab
Spring and the way it's become this you
know this this awful killing ground my
argument I think is that the politics of
the Internet are problematic in and this
is bound up in my critique of the way in
which the Internet lends itself to more
and more individualization it's both a
cause and a consequence of more and more
fragmentation isolation alienation so an
occupy for example when its website or
its marketing was a was a quilt of
individual voices it
the 99% which was I think extremely
problematic because it's a meaningless
term but as the 99% it contained
everyone's voices and everyone was
telling their own story so there's a
broader political problem here in the
old Industrial Age when social class
meant something or an ideology meant
something when we were tied together by
material interests you could see the
emergence of political parties liberals
labor parties in particular conservative
pro-capitalist parties but today on the
internet because of its radical
individualization because of the
echo-chamber nature of its culture
because of the way it isn't really very
social what it really is is just a
platform for our individual voices now I
play around a lot with the idea of the
selfie in in the book and use that as a
sort of battering ram but I think there
is a more serious element in the sense
that we're only going to get political
movements out of the internet when we're
tied together by more than just emotion
and the challenge is to come up with
political organizations and movements
that reflect the reality now the problem
is is the internet movement Stentor and
this comes back to my core argument they
lend themselves to charismatic
leadership so Grillo in Italy for
example is an example of when you these
parties that are supposedly very
democratic and supposedly very open have
a tendency towards opaqueness and a
tendency towards a sort of a narrow
elite who don't really work very much so
I think that that's the fundamental
challenge I don't know what the solution
is but I think when you talk about
distributed politics it's a very vague
concept and I don't know how it works I
don't know what it means and distributed
economics has created new monopolists
like Google so I'm not sure if I even
want distributed politics because it
would lend itself to political process
former capture was a great pleasure
yeah I mean no there's two ways I mean
obviously anyone who starts a company
wants to be a monopolist there's nothing
wrong with that you won a successful
companies buy and that's one of Till's
points that any anyone who starts a
company wants to be in a monopolist cuz
that's that's that's what you want you
want to control the market that's when
your um your most success or I don't
have a problem with that
because that's just sort of it's just
stating the obvious what I do have a
problem with is his idea that monopolies
are good for society I think he he
touches on this he doesn't have a
problem he's very much against antitrust
and I think that's rooted in his idea
that we live in an age where the only
people capable of changing the world are
entrepreneurs so there needs to be
almost different laws for those
entrepreneurs in the 19th century John
Stuart Mill wrote a very important book
called on liberty and we talked about
the intellectual driving civilization
forward that they were the things that
kind of these were the people who
existed outside tradish
no laws for teal it's the entrepreneur
and he seems to think that the
entrepreneurs shouldn't necessarily
conform to the same moral imperatives or
or standards as anyone else and I think
I think he's wrong in both respects I
think monopolies are bad for society and
I don't think that
[Music]
they hire David no I see your point but
I don't I don't agree actually because I
think the answer is what you're talking
about
I would strongly agree I think local
government is much more important than
you know I I don't have the answer for
me isn't global digital government I
don't come up with the idea of
distributed government I agree with you
I don't think we're necessarily
disagreeing I do think that it's harder
and harder to distinguish the internet
from the world and I think one of these
one of the things that we have to sort
of get beyond is always making a
distinction between the real and the
virtual because they're increasingly so
bound up with one another but but I
agree with you I think that and that
comes back to the the solution is
parties if someone can come out with a
better solution I'm open to it but I
just don't know of one well so I mean
one one interesting thing in all of this
right is that you know Saul's tax return
I believe says activists as profession
and
it sounds like to summarize his argument
you could have written a very different
books which was a book trying to inspire
a new labor movement looking for the
dignity of work and looking at the ways
in which underpaid undervalued and under
protected workers underpin a great deal
of what's going on here either in the
literal sense of the Amazon workers that
wouldn't have sold as well as a book
that that sort of takes on the Internet
within its sites are are you are one
place not oh no I could love the books
they could have written I'm interested
in the IMP I'm interested in you know
the Internet is the dominant story of
today it's what everyone's obsessed with
one way or the other and I'm interested
in in in in telling that story and in
understanding that story I could have
written so you say you're saying I
should have written a book in defense of
labor union I I think you could have
written a very important and probably
dusty unread and unloved book on the
importance of labor unions in I think I
could have but I also but I also have
done I've reminded people in this book
of the importance of unions I've
reminded people the doober is against
unions I've reminded people that the
sharing economy isn't about sharing and
you've got people like Jeremy Rifkin in
Europe saying that the sharing economy
will be post-capitalist they'll be I'm
all about sharing it's just complete
garbage so I'm bringing back I mean I
don't if you've read the book but I'm
bringing back concepts that for me are
important the dignity of labor unions
political and economic system which is
relatively equitable and saying that
this digital world isn't isn't creating
them you know I could have written a you
know a 500 page book about the history
of labor unions but I'm not an academic
and I'm not a labor union historian I'm
interested in technology and its impact
on the world
as soon as a letter something to them
dry the vertices weren't equitable
movements as opposed to movements light
yeah that's a good question but
bootstrap meaning I'm not clear on that
word
you mean finance organized well I think
when it comes to or we're already
getting those kinds of movements and in
Europe you've got quite a lot of
movements you have a lot of challenges
say Union challenges to Amazon's labor
practices you have more and more people
and companies in Europe that are
challenging Google and data and Google's
role in the surveillance economy small
companies or movement you know I do
think that entrepreneurs have a big
opportunity here and I was inked I went
to speak at Google a few weeks ago and
someone asked me what's our biggest
challenge and I said your business model
doesn't work and it seems obvious to me
it doesn't seem obvious to anybody else
but I'm wondering whether in 30 or 40
years we'll look back and think that
business model was a failure and it
worked for 10 15 20 years I think you
know coming back to this issue of the
market is that the real opportunity is
we're the entrepreneurs because I I
think say when it comes to data we
haven't had Chernobyl we haven't had
Exxon Valdez we really haven't had the
data catastrophe yet I mean maybe we had
the NSA but that got kind of muddied
because it became an attack on
government rather than on the issue of
the data economy but I think that you
know whether it's Duck Duck
or a number of other companies that are
emerging here which are focused on new
business models is that we need to if
you like educate consumers into
recognizing the value of paying for
things we need them to understand that
when something's for free it's not
really for free so I'm more sympathetic
to market LED solutions here I know it
seems sort of hard to imagine but I
think that people are beginning to wake
up especially in Europe I think to the
implications of the free economy to the
implications of data especially since
were on the verge of this massive
explosion of a day to economy connected
car Internet of Things all the rest of
it and people are going to become more
and more aware of its of its impact on
us privacy is a massive issue and only
becoming larger right I'm with you on
that it is interesting to think about
one ask the question of whether you want
to head towards a move on our head
towards entrepreneurship that at the end
of the day that entrepreneurship is for
you let me just say you know I'm not
against there you know we're in
Cambridge I used to live here I know
about Cambridge in in terms of political
movements but it seems as if the most
effective way for solving a lot of these
problems are market-led one and that we
can fight and shout about uber in
Cambridge and that can have some impact
but the real impact will probably still
come from market-led solutions the
better or worse I'm not necessarily
celebrating there it's just a reality
pick up again use a pretend very quickly
the idea of a decentralized governments
I didn't put it down I just don't
understand what it means so to me it's
very sort of default I suppose so people
who twenty years about how to build
make new standards have discussed it on
mailing lists and things like an
internet Engineering Task Force in the
Web Consortium and so on and they've
done that without country borders being
a part of the party so the hope you know
the web so we built means that we've
never built it out where you don't know
where to communicate they're not aware
of country borders being cost about it
for another you built is country for his
country system and so it's only when we
start to talk about so you know but when
you can talk about dessert you can get
together a whole bunch of people this
guy design a whole new protocol holding
application on the internet and without
really knowing where the people your
combined your your where your colleagues
are and sometimes you know they don't
even like to travel so you not sure
could ever find out so so when you've we
used to support forward progress and
developing a new things including for
example systems you know social systems
like social networking systems which
involve a certain money for the eternal
governments like education basic things
and so on so we build all these systems
and we build it without actually having
to connect to the nation idea at all and
then when something goes badly wrong
like you find somebody in these systems
he's lying who's been fraudulent there's
somebody is abusing them sunny
music you know somebody's breaking the
protocol like somebody knows
intersecting messages changing what's
inside them and sending them on and so
then you think wait
that's not how it's supposed to work but
and then in the only actually then you
have to find out what comes together
because all the all of the because you
have it based on open educational
Association is built on more than that
because the legal systems Regina Kate
from the point of time was when people
were it was very irrelevant to be
geographically stuff but it was all
about whether you could wear in
Cambridge you it was a cliche to live
when you wouldn't have your head chopped
off by somebody else yeah and so on so
now in some case the places it's still
like that still about that but now
anyway if you're truly trying to get
Pete if you're trying to
does out develop if trying to vote new
ways of working for example he's kind of
for example dude but you imagine
yourself developing some sort of new
social system in which people
communicate and do fun things and you
got to try to like they're sort of like
people kind of a schism for the hint if
your student here and you're building
something can we buy the time do a
second technical things we we build
actually affect whether the world is
better or more horrible in the future
because of the properties of onion
things we build on and so to me you have
to be building these things there are
lots of things we've got already which
are not really nation based and so where
that is the default seems to me that so
some people are wondering whether we
should already work like this without
worrying about about nations should
start to put down the basis of them for
example issue start defining to bitter
Constitution so that there's a there's a
generally internationally accepted set
of Constitution levels like the Bill of
Rights you can view your bill of
responsibilities will be welcome there
too and suppose we both we have that as
a backdrop which actually got what has
happened in the in this large internet
yeah
will that can be then use that locally
in each country to sort of to nail home
the actual boring bits of regulations
which have to because you know that's it
is boring to do regulation in one
country because you have to just work in
one country and you open and all you do
will will affect that country but you
have to but everybody has to do that
locally don't you think that there's a
chance of things are people talking
about what they were talking about it
well let me use them but given man let
me bring us a question and ask you a
question given the reality of government
policy in I don't say China and Russia
and Iran and number of other countries
where the the web or the Internet can be
kind of walled off for better or worse
that's what can happen and given
and Turkey is another example given the
way in which authoritarianism seems to
be on the rise and the Internet has
become increasingly an enemy of all the
authoritarian government what can you do
and know these governments are going to
sign these agreements right it's what's
interesting is if to get some countries
which are interested is are interested
in signing agreements likes I give like
this I like Europe in the US for example
suppose Europe in the US come to course
on account some 5000 seem very privacy
in countability
they come together to produce an account
yeah some common promises about how they
will hold their own yeah when the US and
some friends know that's quite a large
chunk if they put together in a an area
in which we have some bail we have some
basic principles which are in which the
normal things which you think I mean and
nasty and horrible then will be yeah I'm
not even convinced that Europe in
America I mean they they're on separate
pages on so many of these issues I'm not
sure whether that's doable so we have to
to political models we have the locals
it was what was that gentleman's name
saw souls the souls model is the local
model Tim's model is the global model
and I have to say that I'm much more
sympathetic to souls muggle because I
just think it's viable I just think that
the the international model is so hard
to realize I don't know how it can work
I mean you go to a lot of these world
internet forum style things what what
have they achieved what do they do or
what about becoming you know bureaucracy
massive bureaucracies where people are
sort of pursuing their own bureaucratic
interests that's technology that's not
politics
but that's technology that's not politic
so you know they don't have got on got
business down and they do stuff now the
question now when it cuts the people who
get together and talk about their
governance they have talked about
talking about their governments they
have not come out with the master plan
and the but so and it's not clear how
that something okay how that's gonna
work
and there's to a certain extent there's
the jurors definitely still have I think
there's no there's a push between people
who would like to who hanker after the
international system yeah there you get
nature's coming together in the UN these
people who want to say let's make a
system which is not really based on
nations at all and there's people are in
between and so on so it's not clear what
would think what people can achieve out
there but certainly the so normally the
areas I work with know there is service
progress and people people compromise
with each other and work with each other
they produce consensus across whiny
people from widely different cultures
and things like that so where the so the
question I think is whether you can take
that sort of spirit and take it on to
making getting global because if you
don't to a certain extent you know these
are multinational season on national
comforters all right all right so
sitting setting it up as a us-based
battle between the American government
with Google is kind of silly because
I'll just moved account already paying
the taxes now and don't move everything
else to Ireland as well and it won't be
an American company more because you
know overnight
ownership review to Google Island or
something so that lady there asked the
question about distributed politics do
you know what that means do you have any
idea about yeah politics which just
isn't but where isn't bound to nation
but by the way we need to know your name
because you're currently in the lead for
the book so
so look just to offer a quick summary
perhaps queue up two more questions
after which we're gonna let Andrew
yes I'm books and have another cup of
tea we've ended up with this provocation
which in which Andrew is basically
saying many of these big problems we'd
hope to solve society the internet
doesn't automatically solve and in fact
in some cases may actually go on to
exacerbate we've gone on to this
question to say okay if we really are
dealing with a radical shift in society
should we not only have a technological
shift at a government ship and I take
that to be previous point about 1812 do
we need to think about not only a shift
in how technologies are made or put out
there but a way in which spaces are
governed and I don't think anyone quite
has a sense for what a distributed
politics is yet Saul put up a highly
localized version Tim put up one which
in many ways is a super technocratic
version it's very distributed within the
space of technocrats but then there's
this long history of where that meets
the politicians and that's the World
Summit on the information society and
neither you nor I are huge fans of where
that interface happens so the invitation
here is for two more questions a
seething new bit better than previous
question of them may be either forward
this debate or lead us in another
direction entirely because there's a lot
within andrew's critique a lot of
different directions to do it I think we
can take one or two more I think it's
really good there we're talking so
politically I mean I think it only makes
my point but the fact that we're really
beginning to address these common there
is no self-evident political solution if
there was I wouldn't have written the
book so I'm gonna give the last two to
so Jordan give me a couple of example
but as that had much of an impact on
anything sure the dream activist yes so
you've had a a movement built largely on
the web around people coming out as
undocumented and unafraid posting their
videos on YouTube yeah they've been that
becoming the dominant narrative that
Obama has picked up which is what got
him to make rather a bold statement
about immigration reform which has won
him lasting emiti of the right
but has actually moved further forward
on immigration which in a while and
that's very much a web-based movement
pushing that forward okay well I would
accept that I think you're right on that
but what I saw so I'll accept that but
what I would say is that we need to know
we've got to figure out the next step of
allowing these single-issue
movements and initiatives online to
mature to flower into more coherent
political organizations so that's an
ideal platform with people telling their
stories but the internet can't
degenerate just into play into a
platform for people to tell their
stories because that's not viable in
political terms that results in anarchy
in anarchy and chaos like like like
occupy so you're right on that example
but I think the Occupy movement is more
interesting and figuring out why why did
it disappear why did it fail
sometimes to organize usurped by
existing people that are trying to paint
okay
I'm gonna look Deb Tufte the last
question and then we're gonna move on to
thanking and funny it's kind of a bit of
a ten dental point but since Cooper was
the universal bad guy I thought I'd end
with that partial defense one of your
three main points was around dignity of
work yeah it's really a critical
dimension to all of this and in some
other context we that I've talked a fair
amount about hyperlocal
so community networks and how if you we
distribute who's doing what in the
community and think about mutual
assistance and self-governance that's
sort of the dignity and something that
doesn't get measured on the commercial
access where we're making all the money
but there's a sort of other dimension
they may not always go together so a
monopoly does that make how does that
how does that connect with the labor
that's involved that it's kind of
leading to those profits so in the case
of over I've actually made habit I use
it's like Amazon I guess
we'll use it yeah it's always typically
they drove and how things change and
usually in terms of pay its roughly
equal to what they made before and I say
and you like it better worse and almost
all of the drivers had prefer why I
control my schedule I work for myself
now I've got this level of freedom and
picking work when I want a flex it's
gonna play I said it's a minor point but
something to hold on to which is
something about than living in this
networking configuration that's actually
touching the lives of people who work
most people work for uber my personal
poll well there as such of the those
people who work for it so you're not
talking if you went into a regular cab
you could talk to a lot of those guys
who'd give you an entirely different
it's a my critique is a broader one of
the the gig economy yeah you know you're
right you're right no one's forcing
anyone to drive uber you're absolutely
right it just as no one's forcing anyone
to rent their homes out on on Airbnb
just as no one's forcing anyone to sell
their labor on TaskRabbit but my point
is to sort of is to say is this the
world we want is this the world we want
a sort of fragmented labor where
everyone's buying and selling their
labor on these increasingly monopolistic
platforms that are taking 30 40 percent
of the revenue and creating enormous
wealth for a tiny group of people
well yeah but to recognize the more
complex nature of what the Internet has
given us and that even in the most evil
character is today in the cab drivers
the uber driver there's something
positive there so as we think about how
to curtail the month the monopoly when
we measure what's happening on the
commercial yeah if you look at the
personal freedom dimension of drivers
it's just I just want to point out in it
yeah it's a fat boy drivers who are
saying personal freedom yay monopoly of
company I work for it I don't like that
go ahead and pull it in but I like this
personal freedom thing this is kind of
working for me so if there's like a
general point which is how do we get
hold on to some of those things that
look like positives while we rein in
some negative argument to just do burr
is it a market like London the better
drivers have knew it before they have
more independence because they're
happier so in fact when you choose
someone who's not you're actually having
a lower standard of quality but not for
the Black Caps they're right right for a
mini cab driver but you also have to
look at the impact on say black cab
drivers and on the years they invest in
in in learning the town and the impact
on on that traditional industry but the
rosemary is just giving you the perfect
thing you can you can deal with amateurs
you can deal with disruptive markets you
could sum it all up in one final
response to that venture I I think I
come back to my point that I'm trying to
take I'm trying to step back and say is
this a world we want so you're right on
them on the micro level yeah people want
to drive an uber car people want to sell
their labor but is this a world we want
is this a world we want of these
increasingly sort of glow
monopolistic platforms taking massive
pieces of our work for profit Travis
kalanick came to dld I was be here in
Munich in January and to get into
European markets he said we'll give you
50,000 new jobs I don't know Travis's
that notion of a job is debatable but at
the same time he came out with that
Larry Summers and Ed Balls the British
Shadow Chancellor of the Exchequer came
out with a important report explaining
why you have the hollowing out of the
middle class and one of the most
important things they came up with this
is this idea of a gig economy where
we're all working part-time perpetually
and that's not a wall I want it's not a
world where people are selling their
labor perpetually I don't think that
benefits working people and I think
coming back to my book it compounds the
winner-take-all economy it compounds
this increasingly monopolistic nature of
the digital economy so I think we have
to separate the fact that sure there are
people you know they're people on
Facebook they like it there are people
everywhere no one's forcing anyone to
use these services no one's forcing
anyone to use Google I use Google but
what I'm trying to do in this book is
get people to step back and say what are
the Mac what what are the macro what is
the macro impact of this on culture on
society on freedom so I try to ask the
big questions rather than simply say
well if people didn't want to do it they
wouldn't do it which of course it's true
so Andrew thank you for some big
questions today
thank you everybody here thank you for a
big discussion coming out of this the
book is for sale at the end of the table
it is in fact I hope people will do it
because buying books on paper is a
wonderful thing if only for nostalgic
reasons let's have a round of applause
attack
[Applause]